(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Pinball,
always an arcade favorite,
but if you grew up in New York
City between 1940 and 1976,
playing pinball meant breaking the law.
In 1933, Congressman Fiorello
LaGuardia was elected
Mayor of New York City.
One of the first items on
his agenda was to crack down
on the mafia.
He honed in on mob-owned slot machines
and surprisingly, pinball machines.
He succeeded in getting pinball declared
an illegal game of change.
And in 1940, the city banned the game.
- I'm gonna stop it.
- [Narrator] This, of course,
drove pinball machines
underground to seedy parlors
and even seedier strip clubs.
But public disdain for
pinball wasn't as high
as it was for slot machines,
which made it hard for the
mayor to gain public support
for his raids on these newly
illegal pinball establishments,
that was until 1941.
After Pearl Harbor, the
government established
the salvage for victory campaign,
which called on Americans
to turn in scrap metal
to be used for the war effort.
Enter Mayor LaGuardia,
who took this opportunity
to seize and destroy more
than 3,000 pinball machines,
all in the name of helping
the military, of course.
Thirty years went past before New
York City declared pinball
a game of skill, not
chance, and legalized it.